okay we're just a little over a week out
from the first democratic debates and
once again the polls continue to move in
fascinating ways and I want to add
something to our analysis today which
are the prediction markets rather than
the polls and I'll explain that in a
second so let's first look at what's
happening with the polls there are now
some very clear trends and these trends
date back six or seven weeks Joe Biden
six or seven weeks ago hit his high
point in polling averaging about 42
percent in the Democratic primary polls
and it has been a steady and continued
decline for him dropping initially to
about 35 then 34 33 and further drops
over the weekend now to an average of 32
with one poll as low as 27 so things not
looking great for Joe Biden and early on
in Joe Biden's declines the declines
were basically becoming Bernie's gains
but that has leveled out for Bernie
more recently Joe's declines have been
Elizabeth Warren's gains remember that
she was polling only four to five
percent at the start of all this and has
very slowly but steadily climbed a point
or a point and a half per month and
again spiking this weekend Elizabeth
Warren now averaging eleven point two
percent in all recent polls a much more
solid frontrunner at this point in time
and then also continuing to make small
gains is Pete Budaj edge now averaging
just under eight close to Elizabeth
Warren and then Kamala Harris keeps
fading she was up to about 13 percent in
February or March and she's had this
slow but steady decline to under seven
now so the trends that we started
observing six to eight weeks ago are
continuing nothing has reversed them so
far and then this is the point where
people have started writing in and
saying but-but-but David what about
instead of looking at polls look at
prediction markets where people bet on
who they think will win rather than just
saying who they plan to vote for because
those can be more accurate than the
actual polls well let's do it and
interestingly enough the prediction
markets look very similar predict ID org
predict it or gravitons rather predict
IT org is one and it has Joe Biden
leading Elizabeth Warren in second place
closely by Bernie and third so that's a
flip from the polls where Bernie is
second and Warren is third then you've
got Buddha judge I mean these are
basically the same numbers as what the
polls say another prediction market
predict wise has it very similar with
just a few tweaks Biden at 29 Warren at
15 Buddha judge 14 Bernie 12 Kamala 11
so again very similar by one or two
percentage points the order is a little
bit different so for everybody who's
writing in to me saying David you've got
to stop looking at polls and you need to
start looking at the prediction markets
because where the money is it tells us
way more about what is going to happen
than where the polls are well the
prediction markets see the numbers
relatively similarly they say that Biden
is ahead and that the front runners
behind Biden seemed to be Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders Budaj edge Harris
in varying orders so what I'm more
interested in seeing is when the debates
start will we see a reversal in any of
these trends and what we also have to
talk about today is another polling
issue which is that a new poll has
Bernie Sanders plus 9 over Donald Trump
in a hypothetical matchup and Joe Biden
plus 10 over Donald Trump I want to talk
about that next